like a lot of fans of the scp foundation
universe we've often theorized about the
coolest versus battles we can imagine
here on scp explained whether it's
warring gods researchers or anomalies
who doesn't love a good fight but ever
since we've started taking mandatory
anger management counseling after the
pudding cup incident in the site 19
break room we've decided to reorient our
focus a little that's why today we're
going to talk about teamwork and
friendship namely which teams
friendships and alliances would lead to
the deadliest outcomes hey look nobody's
perfect but together certain anomalous
duos do have the power to be perfectly
deadly that's why we're going to give
you a whirlwind rundown of our ultimate
matches made in hell these are the
deadliest scp combinations we could
possibly find
scp-096 the shy guy and
scp-035 the possessive mask we begin
with the very duo that inspired this
list as we all know by this point
scp-096 is an indestructible mindless
monster that is extremely distressed by
the idea of somebody seeing its face so
much so that it'll activate the
creature's rage state and result in an
instant and gruesome death for everyone
involved and
scp-035 is an evil mind-controlling mask
that constantly secretes a corrosive
black liquid which gradually breaks down
the bodies of anyone wearing it forcing
it to seek out new hosts if 096 and 035
entered a symbiotic relationship it'd be
curtains for the rest of us as they
enhance each other's strengths and
neutralize each other's weaknesses 096
is unstoppable but mindless and 035 has
a diabolically brilliant mind with no
permanent body wearing
035096 would no longer need to worry
about anyone seeing its face the body
would also regenerate faster than 035's
corrosive slime could melt it resulting
in a host that it could presumably keep
forever with intellect psychic powers
and raw strength and speed there'd truly
be no stopping this horrible abomination
scp-106 the old man and
scp-303 the doorman these two are the
wingman from hell working in tandem to
ensure the ultimate combinations of fear
pain and suffering 106 the monstrous old
man is a pure sadist that can walk
through walls and loves to take his time
torturing his hapless victims with
reckless abandon he's methodical but
slow meaning there's at least a chance
for escape in the short term
scp-303 the doorman is a far more
mysterious beast he appears behind doors
and induces a sense of paralytic terror
within his victims making them
physically unable to open the door until
he materializes to go mess with somebody
else picture this you're just chilling
in your bedroom loving life when you
hear a fizzling sound you look up to see
that it's
scp-106 his grinning face melting
through the wall immediately fight or
flight kicks in but you know you're not
fighting this guy however running can't
save you this time you try to make it to
the door but it's too late you're boxed
in you can see that freakish grinning
langlier on the other side and even with
the horror of the old man on your tail
you just can't summon the will to
overcome the fear and leave it's perfect
for them at least as the old man gets to
really take his time with you knowing
that escape was never really an option
and we're sure 303 just likes to watch
scp-049 the plague doctor and
scp-1765 the sisters a scientific mind
can be a wonderful thing when it's used
for good however when you apply the cold
scientific methodologies of a scientist
to the pursuit of evil you will often
find a far greater depravity than
anything summoned up by a violent
barbarian or brute that's where this
deadly combo comes into play the plague
doctor is a self-proclaimed man of
medical science intent on curing the
pestilence whenever he sees it but
funnily enough this seems to mostly
involve killing people and turning them
into zombies
the sisters similarly are a group of
spectral reality warpers with strong
beliefs that their twisted games are
actually marvelous feats of science like
049 they see themselves as peers to the
scp foundation collecting valuable data
if ever these so-called scientists go
chatting and decided to compare notes
the result would not only be a truly
terrifying brain trust but some of the
most twisted and terrifying experiments
that humankind has ever witnessed and of
course in their own warped minds it
would all be done in the service of the
greater good
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile and
scp-058 the heart of darkness sometimes
the best way to make a new friend is
through a common interest such as just
loving malicious destruction in its
purest forms the hard to destroy reptile
and the heart of darkness both seem to
hate pretty much everything except
causing mass chaos which they're both
extremely good at but we think that they
could be even better at it if they were
working together 682 is able to adapt to
and reverse any attack used against it
and tear through foundation personnel
like a tissue and a paper shredder zero
five eight takes real joy in trampling
whipping things to death with its spiked
tendrils and firing flaming acid out of
its scorpion stinger couple this with
the fact that both are pretty much
indestructible and you've got a duo that
could really paint the town red with
everyone else's blood considering how
extremely difficult it is to wrangle
even one of these monsters the
foundation would need to deploy
everything they have to handle a dual
containment breach and even then it's a
real coin toss as to whether any of them
would even be able to stop this duo of
evil monsters
scp-173 the sculpture and
scp-268 the cap of neglect let's leave
team-ups behind for a second and go back
to this video's roots an iconic anomaly
with a piece of headgear that makes them
way more dangerous in this case it's
scp-173 the sculpture with
scp-268 the cap of neglect
scp-173 is the og and it'll treat your
neck like a wishbone if you don't give
it constant attention this is where a
certain cursed newboy cap comes in 268
is a cap that basically makes you
impossible to pay attention to and its
effects only get stronger the longer you
wear it eventually this leads to the
wearer becoming a kind of unperson
simply impossible to interact with even
when the cap is taken off of course
while this would be a complete
existential nightmare for a human being
wearing it it'd be an absolute dream for
scp-173
after absorbing the cap of neglect's
powers 173 would become a truly
unstoppable killing machine only direct
and constant attention would be able to
keep 173 paralyzed so when it's
physically impossible to pay any kind of
attention to it it also becomes
impossible to stop it could snap itself
across the globe and there's nothing
that any of us could do about it
scp-993 bobble the clown
laugh
and
fun who doesn't love a good crossover
right remember when you watched cartoons
as a kid how exciting it'd be when a
crossover special came on and you got to
see all your favorite characters from
different shows interacting with each
other that's what we're proposing with
the true tv event of the century the
bobble the clown and laugh is fun
crossover this pair of anomalous tv
shows are plenty frightening on their
own bobble being a clown that makes kids
do terrible things and laugh is fun
being a hidden camera prank show that
makes your worst nightmares real the two
of them together would make you laugh so
hard you scream we predict that this
laugh riot might turn into an actual
riot perhaps with their combined powers
they could double their audience and
also double the sinister effects of
their broadcasts needless to say if
these two ever did team up for this
incredible piece of television you'd see
a notable uptick in murders whenever it
was broadcast
scp-4153 it came from site 19 and
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy
there's a well-known phrase in
performing arts the show must go on and
this is certainly a very nice sentiment
until the players are a selection of
living wax mannequins with a major
dramatic streak and the play is an
eldritch horror that causes chaos and
madness wherever and whenever it's
performed that's right
scp-4153 is a selection of living wax
thespians modeled after famous universal
movie monsters and also iconic character
actor vincent price and while they
typically work on the haunted house
circuit they'd love to hit the real
stage even if the heat of the footlights
makes them go a little droopy and what
would be a better play for these
dramatic unkillable weirdos than the
legendary carolinian classic the hanged
king's tragedy it always brings the
house down into an orgy of terror and
bloodshed considering that unlike most
non-anomalous players
scp-4153 may actually survive their
first performance of the tragedy they'd
be free to perform it again and again
and again racking up more bodies each
time but like we said the show must go
on
scp-3280 after the storm and scp-009
red ice a wise time lord once said water
always wins after all you can't even
really kill water you can only change
its form and even then only temporarily
it'll always come back it's in us and
all around us when water goes rogue
there's truly no way of fighting back
it's for that reason that scp-3280 the
nightmarish living water dubbed after
the storm is so terrifying but we know
how we could make it even more dangerous
mixing it with scp-009
red ice this chemically impossible
nightmare converts into ice crystals as
its temperature rises meaning that it
getting inside a human body is a death
sentence as it turns into flesh-rending
ice crystals if you couple that even
more deadly nature of scp-009 into the
frightening speed and intelligence of
scp-3280 and they reach their combined
goal of entering the water cycle then an
xk class end of the world scenario is
basically an inevitability
scp-5049 demon dance discount homunculus
depot and
scp-1879 indoor salesman we'd like to
start this entry by pouring one out for
the original demon dan as fans of our
first video on him may recall his
mysterious demonic superiors blew up his
head after he was captured by the scp
foundation to prevent him from giving up
sensitive information we imagine this
kind of thing happens a lot and it
results in the discount homunculus depot
needing new go-getting salesmen to move
products and meet quotas enter as cp
1879 the indoor salesman and ultimate
hard bargain driver he's
underappreciated at his old job and
looking for work that might lead him to
getting head hunted by scp-5049
and with the increased power given to
him by the demon lords his operation
will move from just covering washington
to popping up anywhere and everywhere
and what's more he might now have a
whole new gaggle of impish assistance
with that kind of setup we can only
imagine he'd be a hell of a boss
scp-4666 the yule man and scp-784
christmas cheer are you longing for the
holidays do you wish it could be
christmas every day trust us you're not
the only one our good friend the
terrifying sadistic yule man also wishes
for a little more christmas considering
he can only actually operate during 12
days out of the year however this
wouldn't be the case if he made himself
a new home just outside of scp-784
the neighborhood where it really is
christmas every single day here it
presumably stands to reason that these
two anomalies could form a terrifying
symbiotic relationship where the yule
man could operate on any day of the year
becoming significantly more dangerous
and taking lives or worse whenever he
feels like it it's safe to say if the
yule man decided to set up a new grotto
in scp-784
he'd be the only one experiencing some
christmas cheer around here
scp-076-2 able and scp-4955
knife if there are three things that you
know about abel it's probably these
three things he's got a potentially
biblical backstory he comes out of a
giant stone coffin and he's really
really good with edged weaponry abel can
produce his own blades from thin air
yanking them out of pocket dimensions
whenever he needs them but personally
we'd think he'd be even more dangerous
if he got his hands on scp-4955
also known simply as knife
knife is an interesting anomaly
initially thought to have anti-memetic
properties seeing as nobody except the
user is able to acknowledge it or
anything it does but the reality is that
it has even more bizarre memetic
properties the knife forces everyone
except the user to play their part in a
huge practical joke where everybody
pretends to not notice the knife or its
actions in order to gaslight the user
however if the knife was in able's hands
the joke would definitely be on them
he'd be the perfect assassin cutting
down scores of victims while nobody
could even acknowledge that he was the
perpetrator
scp-001 the gate guardian and
scp-1179 the centralian fire demon
friends need to have things in common to
make a friendship work after all common
interests are often the basis for all
engaging conversations that's why it
stands to reason that the giant flaming
warrior known as scp-001 the gate
guardian would probably get along
famously with the giant flaming warrior
known as
scp-1179 the centralian fire demon this
devoted soldier of angelic light and his
new cantankerous balrog buddy would
likely have a lot to say to each other
and become an almost unstoppable
fighting duo together they're both
ancient impossibly large with immensely
powerful flame-based weaponry and
presumably a fair bit of battle
knowledge it would also take a truly
special enemy to take on these two
together and even survive let alone win
between them they might even stand a
chance against other impossibly large
creatures like the devourer of worlds
and if nothing else it would likely be
an incredible fight to witness unfold
even if you died immediately after
scp-2094 motor mouth and scp-320
wendigo skull and so we once again
returned to this video's mainstay an
already powerful anomaly being made far
more dangerous by a piece of anomalous
headwear we are nothing if not
consistent folks admittedly scp-2094
also known by his circus stage name
motor mouth isn't exactly an aggressive
anomaly he's a reasonable chatty guy who
just so happens to have an impossibly
stretchy jaw and a seemingly limitless
pocket dimension in his stomach all good
stuff if you're in the mood for some
bizarre party tricks however this
becomes a lot more sinister if he's made
to wear scp-323
also known as the wendigo skull this
cursed skull is imbued with the spirit
of the legendary algonquin monster known
as the wendigo a beast so dangerous that
even saying its name can be risky in
putting on the skull the wearer is
possessed and descends into a state of
violent cannibalism of course this is
bad enough on its own but on someone
like motormouth where there's no real
ceiling on what he's capable of eating
the skull could force him to devour
thousands of people he'd go from a
charming circus act to a hungry weapon
of mass destruction in no time making
these two a deadly scp combination
scp-4973 dead men and
scp-2419 the laughing men well well well
if it isn't the consequences of my own
actions is probably what the foundation
thought when first discovering both
scp-4973
the dead men and
scp-2419 the laughing men that's because
these two groups have something in
common they're the ghoulish remnants of
d-classes killed under foundation watch
and now in their horrible post-death
states they've got a real axe to grind
with their former tormentors
scp-4973 are frightening ghosts that get
revenge on the researchers who
experimented on them in 2419 are a set
of laughing physical abominations that
resulted from all the happy memories
being extracted from d-class corpses for
use in amnestic production if these two
teamed up they'd be a deadly and
terrifying anti-foundation force that
would likely leave mountains of scp
foundation corpses lying in their wake
scp-507 the reluctant dimension hopper
and
scp-2935 oh death here's a not so fun
fact we've all learned in the past few
years when somebody goes somewhere they
shouldn't then bring something
infectious back it's bad for everyone
and nobody goes to more places he
shouldn't than scp-507
also known as the reluctant dimension
hopper though in the poor guy's defense
he really doesn't choose where to go
thanks to his random teleportation
ability however if this resulted in a
sudden trip to scp-2935
an alternate dimension nicknamed o death
it would in turn result in the deadliest
anomalous combination of all time you
see 2935 is infected with the spirit of
death itself wiping out all life on
every level even being the only being in
all recorded realities capable of
instantly and permanently killing
scp-682
and this spirit of death takes
emissaries to spread it across
dimensions wiping out everyone as it
goes and using foundation distress
signals to lure in its next unwitting
herbinger of death the foundation has
blocked off the physical entrance to
this dimension in our world but nothing
is stopping 507 from being reluctantly
teleported there and when he gets back
believe us he'll be bringing an
interesting new friend with him and
there you have it folks the combos
that'll break you what was your favorite
deadly combination of scps we covered
today and do you have any ideas for
killer combos that we didn't cover in
this video let us know down in the
comments and remember kids when it comes
to dangerous anomalies teamwork makes
the nightmare work now go check out
worst ways to die scp edition and
scp-999 tickle monster versus the most
evil scps for more truly superlative
anomalous experiences from scp explained